>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
YOU CAN TELL A LOT ABOUT A
SOCIETY BY WHAT SHOCKS ITS
LEADERS.
FOR GENERATIONS, WHAT SHOCKED
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THIS
COUNTRY WAS POLITICAL VIOLENCE,
HURTING YOUR NEIGHBORS FOR
HAVING DIFFERENT OPINIONS.
THEY WERE APPALLED BY IT AND
THEY WERE RIGHT TO BE.
POLITICAL VIOLENCE ISN’T SIMPLY
AN ASSAULT ON INDIVIDUAL
AMERICANS.
IT’S AN ATTACK ON AMERICA
ITSELF.
IN THIS COUNTRY, WE GOVERNED BY
CONSENT, NOT BY FORCE.
PEOPLE WITH GUNS DON’T MAKE OUR
LAWS.
VOTERS DO.
YOU MAY HAVE A GLOCK IN YOUR
HAND BUT ON ELECTION DAY, YOU
HAVE PRECISELY AS MANY VOTES AS
THE LITTLE OLD LADY WHO
DISAGREES WITH YOU.
THAT’S OUR SYSTEM.
THE WEEK ARE SUPPOSED TO HAVE AS
MUCH POWER OVER THE GOVERNMENT
AS THE STRONG.
THAT’S THE BASIS OF OUR EQUALITY
AS AMERICANS, SOMETHING WE
SHOULD CHERISH AND PROTECT.
POLITICAL VIOLENCE IMMEDIATELY
SHORT-CIRCUITS THIS.
IT ENDS DEMOCRACY.
VIOLENCE INSTEAD RETURNS US THE
MOST PRIMITIVE OF ALL SYSTEMS,
ONE IN WHICH MIGHT MAKES RIGHT.
PEOPLE WHO HURT OTHERS GET TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT.
EVERYONE ELSE HAS TO OBEY THEM.
THERE IS NO GREATER THREAT TO
CIVILIZATION THAN THIS, AND WE
USED TO UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE
IT’S OBVIOUS.
BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
PEOPLE RUN THIS COUNTRY ARE NO
LONGER SHOCKED BY POLITICAL
VIOLENCE.
THEY WELCOME IT.
THEY SLYLY ENCOURAGE IT.
THEY ARE ITS BENEFICIARIES.
THEY TELL US THE ONLY REAL
CRIMES ARE THOUGHT CRIMES.
IT’S OKAY TO SET FIRES OR SMASH
STRANGERS IN THE FACE WITH
TWO-BY-FOURS.
SO LONG AS YOU ARE CHANTING THE
CORRECT SLOGAN.
IF YOU ARE ON THE RIGHT TEAM,
EVERYTHING IS ALLOWED.
BUT IF YOU DARE TO DISSENT FROM
THE ORTHODOXY, YOU WILL BE
SWIFTLY PUNISHED.
GO AHEAD AND EXPRESS THE WRONG
OPINION.
TRY IT IN A MEETING.
TRY IT ON FACEBOOK.
THEY WILL FIND YOU.
YOU LOSE YOUR JOB.
YOUR REPUTATION, POSSIBLY OR
EVEN YOUR LIFE.
THE MESSAGE THEY ARE SENDING YOU
IS VERY CLEAR, AMERICANS ARE NOT
EQUAL ANYMORE.
THERE ARE TWO STANDARDS.
ONE STANDARD FOR THEM AT A VERY
DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR YOU.
OVER THE WEEKEND, WE SAW EXACTLY
WHAT THEY WILL EXCUSE FROM THEIR
OWN SUPPORTERS.
ARMED MOBS OF JOE BIDEN VOTERS
TORCHED BUILDINGS, SMASHED CARS,
ATTACKED POLICE OFFICERS.
THEY RIOTED.
THEY HURT PEOPLE, A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THE MEDIA, WATCHING CLOSELY,
LIED ABOUT ALL OF IT.
THEY PRETENDED THEY DIDN’T
HAPPEN.
THEY MADE EXCUSES FOR IT.
THEY BURIED THE TRUTH IN
EUPHEMISM.
THE LIARS AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DESCRIBED
THE RIOTS AS "PROTESTS."
AS IF THE VIOLENCE WAS JUSTIFIED
OR COULD BE JUSTIFIED.
HERE’S THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
HERE’S WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED IN
SEATTLE OVER THE WEEKEND.
TAKE A LOOK.
[WHISTLES]
[DRUMMING]
[HONKING]
[SHOUTING]
>> ON FIRE!
>> Tucker: PROTESTS.
NO, THESE WERE NOT PROTESTS.
THESE WERE SCENES FROM A WAR.
THE WRITERS THREW ROCKS,
BOTTLES, WOOD, EXPLOSIVES OF
POLICE.
ONE EXPLOSION LEFT AN 8-INCH
HOLE IN A POLICE PRECINCT.
BECAUSE NO LIE IS TO OBSERVE FOR
CNN TO TELL, THEY NEVER
DESCRIBED VIOLENCE AGAINST
POLICE AS "A DEMONSTRATION
AGAINST POLICE VIOLENCE."
GOT THAT?
IT’S A PERFECT INVERSION OF THE
TRUTH WORTHY OF 1984.
IGNORANCE IS STRENGTH.
FREEDOM IS SLAVERY.
WAR IS PEACE.
THEY REPEATED BECAUSE THEY
EXPECT YOU TO BELIEVE IT AND NO
DOUBT SOME DO.
SEATTLE POLICE DEPARTMENT GAMELY
TRIED TO PUSH BACK BY RELEASING
ACTUAL BODY CAM FOOTAGE OF THE
VIOLENCE.
IT’S NOT CLEAR HOW MANY PEOPLE
SAW IT, SO WE’RE GOING TO SHOW
SOME OF IT TO YOU RIGHT HERE.
>> [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]
>> Tucker: A TOTAL OF 59
POLICE OFFICERS WERE INJURED IN
THIS DEMONSTRATION AGAINST
POLICE VIOLENCE.
CNN WOULD LIKE YOU TO BELIEVE
THEY ATTACKED THEMSELVES.
THEY DID NOT.
NOT IN SEATTLE, NOT ANYWHERE.
IN OAKLAND, MOBS WITH HELMETS
AND SHIELDS ATTACKED A POLICE
STATION.
THEY SHOT COPS WITH FIREWORKS.
THEY SET FIRE TO A COURTHOUSE.
HERE ARE PICTURES OF IT.
ACCORDING TO "ABC NEWS," THE
RIOTERS YOU JUST OUR
"PROTESTERS."
THEY BURNED THE COURTHOUSE
"AFTER A PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATION
INTENSIFIED."
OH, INTENSIFIED.
JUST LIKE THE WORLD TRADE CENTER
COLLAPSE WHEN A COMMERCIAL
AIRLINE FLIGHT INTENSIFIED.
IT’S REMARKABLE.
YOU’VE GOT TO BELIEVE THERE ARE
STILL NORMAL PEOPLE WORKING AT
"ABC NEWS," MOVING THE TAPE
LIBRARY OR IN THE CAFETERIA.
ARE THEY WATCHING THEIR OWN
COVERAGE?
HOW CAN THEY STANDARD?
THE APOLOGIES FOR VIOLENCE, THE
RELENTLESS SHAMELESS LYING.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE THEY
HAVEN’T RESIGNED.
THEY PROBABLY HAVE MORTGAGES AND
KIDS.
YOU FEEL FOR THEM, JUST AS YOU
FEEL FOR THE CAMERA MEN WHO HAD
TO FLEE THE MOB IN SACRAMENTO
OVER THE WEEKEND.
THEY WERE SURROUNDED AND
APPARENTLY ASSAULTED BY 150
JOE BIDEN VOTERS DRESSED IN
BLACK PARAMILITARY GEAR AND HAD
TO RUN FOR THEIR LIVES.
YOU THINK OTHER JOURNALISTS
WOULD BE SYMPATHETIC, THE USED
TO BE.
NOT ANYMORE.
THE STAKES ARE TOO HIGH.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION COMING UP
AND SO INSTEAD THEY LIED TO
PROVIDE COVER FOR THE RIOTERS,
THE ONES WHO THREATENED THE
CAMERAMEN.
"THE SACRAMENTO BEE" TOOK PAINS
TO TELL YOU THE PROTESTS WERE
ACTUALLY PEACEFUL.
THE NEWSPAPER DID ITS BEST TO
DOWNPLAY THE VIOLENCE, INCLUDING
THE FACT THAT SO-CALLED
PROTESTERS WERE TRYING TO DISARM
POLICE HELICOPTERS WITH LASER
POINTERS.
ONE OF THE PEACEFUL PROTESTERS
RAN THROUGH THE STREETS WITH A
CHAINSAW IN ORDER TO BLOCK
TRAFFIC.
NO PROBLEM.
NOTHING TO SEE HERE.
MEANWHILE IT MOSTLY PEACEFUL
PROTESTS IN AUSTIN, AND AURORA,
COLORADO, PEOPLE WERE SHOT.
IN DOWNTOWN LOUISVILLE, HEAVILY
ARMED MILITIA IN MILITARY
OUTFITS WALKED TO THE CITY
THREATENING VIOLENCE OF POLICE
OFFICERS WEREN’T SENT TO JAIL.
NO PROBLEM, JUST A PROTEST.
IN THE WALKIE, A BLACK TRUMP
SUPPORTER NAMED BERNELL TRAMMELL
WAS EXECUTED IN FRONT OF HIS
OFFICE IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
HE WAS KILLED.
IN PORTLAND, OREGON, POLICE
SEIZED A BAG WITH RIFLE
MAGAZINES AND MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
NOT A BIG DEAL.
CITY LEADERS IN PORTLAND IGNORED
16 STRAIGHT DAYS OF WRITING.
IT’S FINE, THEY SAID.
REALLY?
HERE’S HOW PORTLAND LOOKED OVER
THE WEEKEND.
>> [BLEEP]
[POPPING]
[BLEEP]
>> HEY, HEY, HEY.
>> Tucker: THIS ISN’T FINE.
IT’S NOT NORMAL.
IT’S NOT A PROTEST.
THESE AREN’T CHILDREN.
THESE ARE ADULTS, AND THEY ARE
DESTROYING OUR COUNTRY.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY OUT OF
CONTROL.
THEY ARE VIOLENT.
ARE THEY PUNISHED?
NO.
WHERE’S THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
IN THIS?
DON’T WE HAVE AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL?
ISN’T HE SUPPOSED TO BE
CONSERVATIVE?
WHY ARE WE ALLOWING IT?
CHAD WOLF RUNS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, HE’S BEEN ONE
OF A FEW OFFICIALS IN WASHINGTON
WHO SEEMS TO NOTICE THAT ANY OF
THIS IS HAPPENING.
HE SENT FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO PORTLAND TO GIVE THEM ALL
FROM BURNING DOWN THE FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE THERE WHICH THE MOB
DOES NOT OWN.
ITS FEDERAL PROPERTY.
THEY HAVE NO RIGHT TO CHARGE IT.
IT’S NOT THERE IS.
IT’S OURS.
FOR DOING THAT, FOR BEING ONE OF
THE VERY FEW TO ACTUALLY PUSH
BACK A LITTLE BIT, HE WAS
PUNISHED.
THE MOB CAME TO CHAPEL’S HOME
YESTERDAY, THEY THREATENED HIM
AND HIS FAMILY.
THEY DIDN’T DO IT SUBTLY.
THEY SET IT OUT LOUD TO CAMERA.
WATCH.
>> WE MUST MAKE SOCIAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE MEN AND
WOMEN.
WE MUST MAKE IT UNCOMFORTABLE
FOR THEM.
WE WILLWE ARE ANGRY NEIGHBORS.
YOU CAN’T LIVE HERE QUIETLY.
ABLE TO LIVE JUST LIKE US.
>> Tucker: OH, STARTING TO
FIGURE OUT WHY THE DEPARTMENT OF
ISN’T ACTUALLY DOING ANYTHING,
WHY THEY HAVEN’T FROG MARCH THE
LEADERS OF ANTIFA IN FRONT OF
THE CAMERA AND WHY THEY HAVEN’T
STOPPED THIS AND WHY THEY ARE
ACTING LIKE THEY ARE POWERLESS.
MAYBE THEY DON’T WANT MOBS LIKE
THIS IN FRONT OF THEIR HOUSES.
MAYBE MOB VIOLENCE WORKS.
WE MUST MAKE IT UNCOMFORTABLE
FOR THEM, SHE SAYS, IN A
MEGAPHONE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WE DON’T NEED TO GUESS BECAUSE
WE JUST SPENT ALL WEEKEND
WATCHING WHAT IT MEANS.
HERE’S THE CONTRAST WE SHOULD
NEVER FORGET.
THINGS CHANGE SO QUICKLY YOU
IMAGINE THINGS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
THIS WAY BUT THEY HAVEN’T.
THERE’S A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
A FEW MONTHS FROM NOW.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH WHAT CHAD
WOLF HAS DONE, YOU GET TO VOTE
AGAINST CHAD WOLF’S BOSS, AND
CHAD WOLF WILL BE OUT OF A JOB.
THAT’S THE WAY WE USED TO DO IT
WHEN THIS WAS A DEMOCRACY.
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
NOW THEY JUST GO AND THREATEN
CHAD WOLF’S CHILDREN.
IN THE MEDIA APPLAUDS.
LAST MONTH, A RADIO SHOW HOST IN
SEATTLE CALLED PAUL GALLANT
MOCKED A REPORT HE SAID HE WAS
DESCENDING INTO CHAOS.
THESE WERE PEACEFUL PROTESTS HE
SUGGESTED.
HE REPORTED ON TWITTER HE SAW NO
BURNING, PILLAGING OR DEATH.
THOSE THINGS WERE HAPPENING.
THEY EXIST.
WE SHOWED YOU TAPE OF IT AT THE
TIME.
BUT GALLANT PRETENDED OTHERWISE.
WE ASSUME IT WAS BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT IT WAS HELP HIS TEAM AND
THEN THE RIOTERS SHOWED UP IN
THE BUILDING WHERE HE LIVES, HIS
APARTMENT BUILDING.
THEY DESTROYED THE STARBUCKS
DOWN STAIRS AND THAT SCARED HIM.
NOW GALLANT SAYS HE IS BUYING A
GUN.